normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government how
long were you with The Offspring 14 14
years at this point 14 years yeah and so
I'm like wellow that was a really weird
phone call like that you know that seems
unnecessary and I took it to the band
they backed him up didn't didn't matter
and everything deteriorated really
quickly after that and then you know
basically overnight just ghosted like I
found out I was replaced I checked my
Southwest app my flight to rehearsal had
been canceled my access to the band work
calendar was revoked later the same day
and that was just it it was just like
you your family everybody doesn't matter
you're race and it's you know they say
like you find out who your friends are
but it's like when you're in a band and
you guys can attest to this too your
family like some years you spend more
time on the road with these people than
you spend with your own family and you
know everything everyone's your family
and but you find out where you are where
you really stand the first time you say
no to something and you know you know
that's this was the first no that I had
given and I was gone this sounds like uh
it sounds like the Soviet Union it
sounds like how Communists behaved uh in
Salan and things like that that you were
a terrifying other and you were not
adhering to uh uh what do they what do
they call those things um uh there's
there's a phrase for I don't I got to
listen to more James Lindsay like uh
front lines or something like that or I
don't know some phrase where it's like
there's an a narrative everyone must
follow no matter what don't question it
stay in line don't back off and so when
you are even legitimately through
medical reason no no no there what is it
no no no no there's a word for there's a
word for acceptable narratives like you
must agree with the Ukraine war you must
agree with the lockdowns you must agree
with the vaccinations you must side with
these political issues and if you don't
then you're you're outside it's crazy
that like you were saying before before
covid and I would actually add I think
before the Trump era whatever you want
to call it if you were a a different
political background like you could
still be friends it was like oh I don't
know I guess and then we talk now all of
a sudden it's like bro they didn't even
call you they were just like quick quick
delete his make him go away we don't
even want to hear his name anymore
that's like weird cult level yeah not
just me to me it was like my whole
family you know our wives were really
close our kids grew up together and you
know and for me the the reason that I
didn't I didn't say anything at first
like I took a month to kind of clear my
head and like see what would happen cuz
I'm just ghosted so I'm like well maybe
I'll hear something back and so nobody
said anything and then they've got a
tour coming up and they've got shows
they had a show in Nashville where I
live and people are hitting me up for
tickets for all these shows that I know
I'm I won't be at anymore so it was like
all right well what do we do here I
don't want to have this conversation 500
different times so you know drafted up a
statement was pretty nice explaining
just basically here's here's why I won't
be there anymore and say anything bad
about anyone and was just like you know
but also said I I don't think this is
right I don't think anybody should be
forced to get this by their employer by
the government by anyone you know and
and so if anybody else feels left out
and lost here like got your back you
know understood and I just figured
firing squad you know flamethrowers and
that would be that but yeah shout out to
the chat it's Mass line it's uh the
political organizational and Leadership
method developed by Mao zetong and the
Chinese Communist party it refers to
formulating policy based on Theory
implementing it based on people's real
world conditions revising Theory and
policy based on actual practice etc etc
but um people make references to like
the Ukraine war starts you must agree
with it and so you end up with this
weird circumstance where the American
political left as we describe it is
critical of the military-industrial
complex supportive of the
military-industrial complex in favor of
pro-choice because my body my choice my
I choose my medical practice but then
you should be forced to undergo Medical
Treatments completely none of none of
these things align logically they align
politically and it's it it's any there's
no logic to it but that is what you must
adhere to right when it comes to the US
funding of you know Israel for instance
they're like no this is bad we shouldn't
do it when it comes to the US funding of
Ukraine it's like Yay you know those
Russians are bad when it comes to uh uh
medical treatment it's my body my choice
except if it's pertaining to lockdowns
and mandates yeah no logic it was
bizarre zero logic and that's the thing
and and then I had people you know
online coming at me like and people I
knew coming at me going oh well you're
you're this rightwing thing now or
you're this or that which I that's not
insulting to me like I I'm friends of
all political Stripes but it it was just
bizarre that it's like okay if you won't
do this thing here's the laundry list of
things we're going to call you that we
think are terrible but it didn't make
any sense I'm like I'm standing in the
exact place that I've always been I
voted for Bernie Sanders I'm you know
have people yelling Trump supporter just
cuz I wouldn't take the vaccine I'm like
it's not an insult but it's not accurate
they don't care but I thought we weren't
putting you know labels on people that
they didn't ascribe to I love that like
so you're not queueing on I'm not yeah
go figure right I figured that was the
guy from The Offspring the whole time
man you're not is but did did any of of
you of the other guys in the band any of
you guys experience similar similar
things like refusing to ad here to
lockdowns or anything like that or is it
just these is that is that why these
guys are sitting here at the table I
mean luckily luckily I live in in Texas
right so it's it was it's not an issue
it never even really came up I just
Dicky and Pete are my friends and it was
like uh holy crap what's happening to
them is so crazy and wrong and how can I
be there for my friends kind of thing
man that's crazy that's awesome but
that's nice right yeah but that's normal
but that's for all the people that ran
ran from you there's this other group of
people that ran towards you you know and
and you kind of like my wife said well
you know we we're not going to hide here
how do we how do we find our people how
do we find our tribe and for me it was
mostly like to to speak out and say
something because I know tons of people
got fake cards tons of musicians
everybody went back to work kept their
head down I'm just going to ride this
out that's cool but for me and my kids
do you want me to list those names no
we're
good know I know a bunch of them a lot
of people probably do but I'll tell you
guys what man Tim wants me to list them
you know I'm 50/50 some people deserve
privacy depend if they're Hypocrites and
they're evil and they're doing nasty
things you call them out but I you know
you talk about the people rushing
towards you I'm pretty sure my mom I
don't know for sure but I'm pretty sure
she cried when she found out that Pete
Pata the drummer for The Offspring was
was playing drums with us cuz when I was
a little kid playing Offspring songs and
she's bringing like guitar lessons or
whatever this is the band these are the
CDs I got the tab books for xan on the
Ombre smash all at once and I'm at home
I'm playing it all and then one day
she's like The Offspring drummer is is
playing drums with you you like this is
so amazing I'm like well I don't know
man I mean it's crazy and then for Ian
when we mentioned that you were coming
Dicky yeah Ian starts listening off all
the albums he used to listen to Royal o
man dude screw these people I've spent
the day with Ian I wish your mother
liked me no I'm just Kidd she probably
does it is interesting how if you're a
kid and you have like a hero that you
look up to and then you live your truest
self publicly that you may end up
working with them like that is
mindblowing but maybe you wouldn't want
to
like you know look I I I my my mom was
when I was little she's like oh you know
Dexter Holland he's getting his PhD and
all that stuff like she was so proud
that I was looking up to a band where
the lead singer this rock star was also
getting an education and I did think
that was really great you know Tim he
flies his own plane that's true yeah you
know he's a rocket scientist that's
fantastic and he's a bad person he's a
he's a bad guy because I I just I I got
I got you know if if there's no there's
no excuse man he broke young Tim
skateboarding young 13-year-old heart
child me is like learning now and and is
smashing guitar in the background what a
great guy Pete is I I yeah I mean I
would push back on anyone being bad
people I think sometimes people make
choices that I would consider bad I
didn't enjoy the choice they made for me
um I don't think they're bad people we
were friends right up until I never
heard from them again you know you
you're a nice guy Pete you're a nice guy
but I gotta tell you if here here here
here's how I imagine the circumstance
right they're a big touring band right
they're doing a bunch of shows and these
venues mandate it because the government
mandates it but the venues weren't not
all the venues were the venues weren't
mandating it it would they left well I
guess on the audience so yeah some some
venues were saying you know we' even
worse than I thought but I know plenty
of bands that had you know someone had a
medical exemption and it was accepted
it's not like they were clamping down
cuz no one wanted to cancel shows for
any reason it was just show us a piece
of paper
come play your show whether it says you
got it or you can't get it is is it
public how much they made when they did
shows like what their Rate rates were I
don't want I don't want to out anybody's
private business stuff but I don't know
if it's like publicly known or something
I don't know I don't even know myself so
I'll just I'll just say you know it it's
they're not poor right and my view is if
I had a band if I had a show if anyone
at timcast and we are going to do shows
we're going to do a bunch of venue stuff
and something like this happened there's
no way in hell I would cut off
communication and and terminate someone
I'd worked with for 14 years my worst
case scenario would be something like
I'd go to up and I'd say we got your
back we'll keep you in the studio as
long as we can when when when we can get
you back on on on the shows you're there
we'll keep paying you come hang out the
venue doesn't let you in screw them we
may have to get a touring drummer but we
we got you man we're here with you on
this one I wasn't allowed in the studio
either but that's that's that's that
that's it well that's the thing though
I'm like none what I was trying the
conversation I was trying to have with
them was hey we don't know know yet you
know the manager screaming at me well
there's borders you can't cross and
there I'm like well which ones well we
don't know yet I great we don't know yet
there's venues you can't get into which
venues well we don't know yet I'm like
well then why are like it just felt like
it was a little soon to pull the trigger
on get this or get out Y and then they
go on tour and I'm getting text messages
and Instagram messages from all these
other bands then they're like dude we're
on the same festival with your old band
today none of us got the shot nobody
asked us for papers or anything and I'm
like I know that
you know that but I can't
get yeah there was no there was no venue
the fall of 2021 there was no venue in
the United States that I could not have
played with them there I CH I looked up
everyone believe me until I finally had
to just stop caring for my own sanity
and and uh mental safety and um but you
know once they went to England in
October November yeah I wouldn't have
been allowed to go there and I
understand that but then then I tell you
like
I would I would outright just be like
bro uh if you can't come in the studio
because they won't let you if they can't
let you enter the board my my response
would not be well you can't cross the
border if you can't work with us my
respons would be looks like you're
getting a year where we're going to pay
you because we're not letting you come
uh keep an eye out and we'll go through
all the fine details as soon as we can
get you when we get you in if you can
come in this country you're with us if
not hang out at home and uh we'll keep
paying you yeah it was it wasn't about
that it was just you you can't say no to
people that are you know well of course
I was not in a position so many people
though it's also just Optics they don't
they don't they don't want the
controversy they just want to be able to
say that yeah everyone's everyone's that
man it's it's such a bomber but I think
we're winning on this front it's not
just about you know co uh Trump was also
that there's like a similar thing here
but Co was really like with Trump
there's a lot of people voted for him
but kept their mouth shut with Co it was
just like 10x I'm worried something like
this happens again where it's a mass
line you must adhere no matter what
white lung white L you know I don't
think it'll be white lung people are you
know people are pointing out like it's
it's affecting kids and that's a problem
for sure but is that the way back in
though because you know Co wasn't
affecting kids and that was that was the
one thing they couldn't convince people
and I think that yeah that's suspect
right things to kind of crumble but this
one out of no mistake about it this time
it's affecting kids but I mean like with
with Trump's campaign a lot of people
kept their mouths shut because they
didn't want to be added as a trump
supporter but there was no harsh extreme
authoritarianism you're not locked in
your home then they do the lockdowns and
it's the same thing it's the it's the
political line you must adhere to no
matter what and the punishment was 10
times more severe Co was like no like
how many well just sorry but like there
are some people who got fired for being
Trump supporters but early on it wasn't
as pronounced there are some musicians
who were accused of being at January 6
they got fired but like the co stuff is
outright take a medical treatment and in
your instance against the advice of your
own doctor and that's crazy because you
should definitely just not listen to
strangers and listen to your doctor and
the the the level of
this is what I mean if you supported
Trump or didn't support Trump it's kind
of like who cares you know but people
were weird about it if you couldn't get
a medical treatment they destroyed your
life yeah the the next level of this
follow the line or else terrifies me
it's it's gogs it's do it or we putting
you in a in a you're going to go break
rocks I I feel like the co the co
experience was like a a psychological
vaccination on the human consciousness
like it was such intense fear propaganda
and numbers being flashed on CNN death
numbers these horror horror horror
scaring people insane and then numbers
start to come out that it's like a
99.7% survival rate and you're like what
in the hell did we just do for 2 years
and now people are like immune to this
and not 100% but it's like we're ready
for this kind of stupid fear prop now
like I'm I'm hyper Vigilant against fear
propaganda at the moment and I know a
lot a lot of other people that are that
weren't in 2020 well but even at at the
time in in 21 I mean people like me that
got let go other band people from bands
all around that got fired my guys went
on tour they all caught Co anyway I
wasn't there to blame like it it didn't
matter you know it was just about
getting everybody in line like we we
everyone has to do this we're not going
to have any denters in the camp you know
it exposed a lot of people a lot of a
lot of bad people yeah and now or you
don't agree with bad people but it
exposed a lot of bad of people who are
willing to engage in dark Deeds there
you
go
I'll meet you there I'm just saying like
yeah but I for me with the the white
lung or whatever the new thing that the
fact that this new the newest round of
the vaccine that the brand new one that
nobody wants there's another round or
there's a new an updated booster right
so now they're saying what hok in New
York was like well if you got the other
ones it doesn't matter now now you need
this new one cuz nobody wants it I think
it's up to 14% uptake so it's like does
that make the other 86% of Americans
antivaxers now thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net